joining us now is cbs news national
security contributor michael morrell he
is a former acting and deputy director
of the cia michael good morning to you
the split screen internationally is
really stark inside ukraine they're
handing out ak-47s residents are being
told to prepare molotov cocktails in
kiev and then internationally there are
sanctions being applied is there
anything more that the global community
can do now to stop russia's advance
tony i don't think there's anything we
can do
to stop what putin is doing in ukraine i
think the objective now of the west and
the united states is to impose such pain
and such cost on putin that he doesn't
do this elsewhere most importantly in
the baltics which as you know are
members of nato so i don't think there's
anything we can do to stop this but we
can stop something in the future with
the right approach now
gail is joining us from los angeles and
has a question for you gail
i do mike you know what i think is so
interesting the american government has
been been predicting this for weeks it's
coming it's coming it's coming it's
going to happen
a was there anything anything we could
have done to head this off at the past
number one and number two
now that it's here the way it was
predicted
what is president biden's dilemma what
is his biggest challenge right now
so gail i really don't think there's
anything we could have done i think the
biden administration handled this as
well as they could
um you know we tried to end it at the
negotiating table
um
you know we we provided weapons to uh
the ukrainians um
so there's i don't think there's
anything we could have done to stop it
but the president's dilemma now is
on the one side he has to impose
significant costs on putin
um to stop him from doing this someplace
else in mondovo in in moldova or in the
baltics
but he can't at the same time right
impose such costs that it hurts american
consumers at the gas pump or it hurts
europeans ability to heat their homes
this winter
so he has to he has to balance those two
things and i think where we are right
now since we haven't hit the energy
sector which is 30
of the russian economy 60 of their
exports since we haven't hit that
i think that vladimir putin
right now sees weakness on the part of
the west rather than strength
why is this so important to him mike i
know you're someone you're very familiar
with with putin the man the person how
he operates what can you say about that
and why is this so important to him
it's important to him gail for two
reasons one is um one is nato right and
russia has in ba has been invaded more
often than any other country in the
world and that gives it a psychology of
needing a buffer between its borders and
its adversaries that's why the nato
issue matters i think that's 25 of this
75 percent of this scale is that is
domestic politics vladimir putin is
deeply afraid of a ukraine that is a
vibrant democracy a vibrant economy tied
to the west because he fears that his
people will see that and they'll say
they want the same thing um so seven 25
nato 75 domestic politics in russia
all right michael morell for us we hope
that uh putin is still a rational actor
in this because if he's rational at
least potentially he can be stopped here
we appreciate your perspective thank you
very much welcome